out in the wild nothing gets me more
excited than a mountain lion
look at this spot this is the lion's
lair this is the ambush zone
and if you're a mountain lion a few
things taste better than a big horn
sheep and this old boy
he went out in a tough way
fighting a mountain lion
in rugged terrain only mountain lions
can take down giant bighorn
and with lions on the prowl these iconic
animals struggle to survive
there's so many things
i love to have a little lamb like this
for lunch
in some wild places lions eat bighorn
faster than the sheep can breed
tracking lions is my passion
but saving bighorn is my priority
one thing is for sure about lion chasing
it's never easy
if lions eat all the sheep then their
own future's in jeopardy
so i'm going to the extreme to save the
bighorn and the lion
this is america
yeah
the wild
well there's tracks everywhere out here
but i've looked at maybe
300 boulders
thinking i've found my bighorn finally
hmm no not yet
eventually one of those boulders
not just one big horn
the entire herd
i'm here to witness a spectacle i've
never seen
the
rut but i'm not alone
mountain lions are here too
and bighorn are some of their favorite
food
man it's to be this close these awesome
big rams
amazing
and just to see how they're built
those massive horns
those things got away close to 35 pounds
i know a lot about lions but i'm just a
rookie when it comes to their prey
that was my first headbutt
oh yeah there we go
the hormones the testosterone has made
these things into like rockets
you know bighorn sheep look invincible
but not so long ago you could barely
find one anywhere
wild bighorn were decimated
they're gradually coming back
but in some places lions are killing
more sheep than the herd can sustain ah
that is so cool
oh check this out right here
this is a looks like a young
you you can see the very petite bones
oh wait there's another there's another
bone right here check this out it's
another bone this is the femur
of a sheep
this is not from the same animal
you look at the petite size of these
ribs and there's a lot of connective
tissue left over
this guy's a little bit older this comes
from an adult animal
and this looks like a perfect ambush
zone right here
look at this spot this is the lion's
lair
oh
jackpot right up here check this out
look at this
this spot
has been going off for years this has
been an ambush zone forever just look
how old this is
and this is not your ordinary skull
if you look at all these little holes
in the skull
all these sinuses
those actually act as like bubble wrap
it makes them
one of the strongest skulls on the
planet
and this old boy
he went out in a tough way
fighting a mountain lion
this terrain is so gnarly the only
predator capable of taking down an adult
bighorn sheep is the mountain lion
that's it
but this is a real problem
because they're killing an animal that's
already struggling to survive
i really want to learn how a mountain
lion has the skills to take down a
bighorn sheep and the only way to do
that is with the help of some friends
look at you guys last time i saw these
guys they were each the size of a loaf
of bread
not too long ago i met two little tiny
mountain lion kittens callie and kaya
and i got to interact with them
now they're bigger they're nearly adults
and they're gonna have the ability to
show me what an adult mountain lion can
do
but i also brought along another friend
his name is roosevelt the ram
okay mr roosevelt
every time i use these decoys i'm always
really surprised how
anatomically correct they are
now stay right there
good boy
if you think it's cool to let her off
i'll start creeping him forward and
we'll see what happens okay
she's off
[Music]
she's locked in
now what's important to remember here is
that neither of these cats has ever had
to kill any live animal before
she's being really
methodical about her steps she's really
creeping in slowly
look at her
she's focused
get in the position she's going to go
for the neck
roosevelt moves forward she gets up on
the stump right in front of roosevelt
looks him right in the eye and says dude
you better get off my mountain kapow
right in the snot knocker
it's not knocker
definitely not normal mountain lion
predatory behavior but the good news is
i got kaya
okay
she's off
she's gonna find him here and she's
gonna be surprised
she's still she's gonna be a freak no
look at that right for the neck
there's something i'm gonna kill it swam
bam good plate in the neck game over
she goes straight for his throat claws
teeth out and she exhibited her natural
instincts to kill
out of nowhere mountain lands on its
back
it's game over
cat's on your back already dude you're
done
[Applause]
seeing kai in action going for the kill
man i wouldn't want to be a sheep out
here on this hillside especially in an
ambush zone
i mean i know what it's like to be
attacked by a lion
i've got the scars to prove it
and now i feel like we're blood brothers
and it just gives me all the more
respect for these predators
i actually
smelled it before i saw it and this
might be exactly what i'm looking for
look right
here poop look at that poop
now that might look just like a pile of
scat but what you're looking at right
here
is one
giant litter box
and it is everywhere there is a lot of
really
recent activity look at this right here
and there's scat everywhere
really really fresh tracks right here
mountain lion tracks coming down the
hill right here
oh
look at this
big track
little track
that means one thing we've got a family
group
at least two lions that explains all
that scat that giant litter box
the other thing is all this activity all
this back and forth here
all this fresh
tracks going over the litter box
there's probably a kill
really really close i'm gonna get up on
this knob
look around
we definitely have a mountain lion
right here somewhere
and i had fresh mountain tracks right
here and now i have
i've lost them
we got scavengers in the air there's
eagles ravens and magpies
sworn around
we've definitely got a kill around here
somewhere we just gotta look for it
dude
look at this look at this look at this
cat kill right here cat kill
look at this there's two elk here i've
never ever ever seen this before
and this is definitely mountain lion
kill
that this doesn't even make sense
this mountain lion killed two elk at the
same time
so i don't know what happened here i
don't know if you know mom got one of
the elk and the kitten got one on the
elk and i drug him in here
now
they've got like the ultimate mountain
lion buffet
and there's a lot of meat left
you know when they kill an elk like this
they'll bring it in here and the first
thing they do is go right into the rib
cage
and eat the heart and lungs
and
you know big toms big males they'll
break the neck of an elk like this
but females and young when they kill
something sometimes what happens is they
do it by suffocation they'll literally
come right around
and they bite right like this right on
the face close that mouth down and hold
until the elk stops breathing and if you
look at both
of these elk
their mouths are
they're close shut
and they were close shut by the jaws of
a mountain lion
you know i've tracked mountain lions
before i've filmed their kills but this
kill this is unique to elk
i have a lot to learn here there's no
way i'm walking away from this scene
i'm gonna set up my blind i'm gonna be
here tonight when that mountain lion
comes back
[Music]
there's something
there's something right down there in
the safebrush
this mountain lion has moved in
very very slow a lot of thought
even though it's moving into its skill
it knows there could be other animals
around and it's being very very cautious
we've got another one coming up
this is good
definitely
another mountain lion so this looks like
it's confirming
female with the young
yep
amazing amazing amazing
right now
i can see one of the
is
non-lions
sniffing one of my cameras
that is in your face
don't eat the camera buddy eat the elk
okay now this is getting interesting
i've got three mount lions
there are three
no wonder that you'll do elk
this is awesome
so now i have got a full-size family
group of mountain lions right here
three
nearly full-grown mountain lions no
wonder they can kill two elk imagine
what they could do to a herd of bighorn
[Music]
i'm literally sitting here right now
to teeth
crunching bones
right over there
he spent a lot of time
hoping that these moments happen and
then when they happen it's just
i don't know if i'll ever get to see it
again i mean it's that rare this could
be my last time ever witnessing mountain
lions in a while
so you definitely cherish every
opportunity you get
and tonight
has been incredible
oh look at this
this is the hoof of a little mule deer
fawn probably killed by mountain lions
right here in the same area
here in the rocky mountains the lions
have loads of things on their menu and
the predators and prey are pretty much
in balance
but in the sonoran desert the balance is
gone same predator same prey but there
are very few sheep and way too many
mountain lions and that's not good for
the mountain lion
i mean lions are doing what lions do
but if they wipe out their prey base
they put themselves at risk too
so it's really hard to know what's the
solution
i'm here in southwest new mexico and the
operation the mission is basically save
the desert bighorn and i'm in for the
ride of my life
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is where the mugging begins right
now
[Applause]
wow right in this gnarly stuff here
well
here i am up close to a desert big horn
that's some desert vegetation yeah i
mean this place is gnarly
does not make these captures easy at all
now these animals are gnarly they're
tough
desert bighorn might be tough but
they're in real trouble diseases killed
off most of them get that blindfold on
it'll make her feel a little secure
while we
untangle this mess now mountain lions
are killing the rest so there's this
awesome high-tech operation going on to
save them
last thing you want out here is an
ocotillo in the butt and a hoof in the
face hubble them up they feel secure
that's what we want
she's blindfolded she's hobbled
we'll get her secure in a bag and get
her back to the base as soon as possible
here well i think what we'll do is we'll
land the helicopter right here on this
little
ridge if you can just hold her in your
lap put her nose out the window and i'm
like what
this poor gal has no idea what's in
store
and neither do i
this is certainly something new
flying over the desert man it couldn't
be more different than the rockies
in the rockies the predators and prey
are in balance
down here sheep are definitely losing
the battle to the mountain lion
so there's a huge effort going on to
reintroduce sheep and increase their
numbers
and it starts with monitoring their
precious lambs
i mean that was a wild ride what do you
got there this is a pretty complicated
process
about 62 kilos step one catch a u this
is a rat snap as they say step two see
if she's pregnant there's a fetus you
can see the ribcage you can actually see
the heart in the upper part of the
screen to the right and you see the
heart beating
then they insert this special vaginal
transmitter so they can find the lamb
when they're born
step four will be monitoring the lambs
to see how many the lions are killing
so the low point for desert bighorn
sheep was probably in the late 1970s
when we had less than 70 sheep in the
wild and that's when we started to try
and increase hard numbers
so
we've implanted the vaginal implant and
once this pregnant you has a lamb that's
going to come out and the temperature's
going to change it's going to get cooler
indicating the birth of the lamb now we
only got about 48 hours to find the you
and the lamb to get a color on that lamb
and the only way we can do that is with
this radial color right here that we're
fastening on
she has been processed and she's ready
to rock and roll and that was quick
that's what we try you ready keep the
stress down i'm ready
[Applause]
there you go
hopefully the next time we see her she's
got a healthy little lamb with her
but my day is far from over
we've got to process 20 pregnant use
before sunset
and they're scattered all over the
desert
i mean this is like the wild west out
here we've got guns we've got
helicopters we got cowboys and it's like
a rodeo
[Music]
these guys are crazy
diving down these goalies just doing all
these crazy moves
pow that net comes out and goes over the
animal
hopefully
but just a little behind okay no problem
hold on watch the raw i got it okay
coming in with some pedal you ready
stuart yep ready okay anytime
three two one now
so now i have to get on the ground jump
out of this helicopter trying to get my
head chopped off by the rotor
so now we got our tangle in the net
gotta try to get her untangled we have
to get this animal back to the base camp
as soon as possible and if i mess up
that animal's life's at stake
that's gonna be good enough we'll go
ahead and go over do you have a bag up
there
no i do not
you gotta be kidding me
[Music]
we're kicking butt we're getting a lot
of use we're slinging them back to base
camp
65 kilos she is pregnant you do it quick
and painless
every second counts there can never be
too many hands here at this pit stop
x marks the spot
on her butt here
that's actually to make sure when we go
back out
looking for use we will not recapture
this animal
and that was quick that was like way
better than a nascar pit stop
you know there's a lot of effort going
on to save the desert bighorn and that's
great
it's such an important animal
but so is the mountain lion and i hate
that down here it's a big part of the
problem
so i need to find out why
it's this old age-old thing cat versus
dog here
and without these guys there's no way
we'd even get close to this cat
there are mountain lions all over the
desert southwest and arizona game and
fish are watching their every move
which means i can find out why the lions
are hitting the bighorn so much harder
down here than up in the rockies
crystal come here
so just as the sun come up this morning
we got a signal of a cat she was
actually really close right at the base
of this mountain but as soon as we let
the dogs out the dog started barking she
heard that and she's gone over the top
so now we gotta get the dogs close
hopefully pick up her scent
and then the chase is on
lions have to be really gritty to
survive out here in the desert
and man that's where the story gets
tough because you know i love mountain
lions
but if these cats are eating all the
bighorn then there's some tough
decisions to make
so when i
have chased lines in the past in montana
a lot of real big trees for those cats
to run
get up in i don't see any trees around
here
boomer hey come here back back back
you weren't lying you said
that you're going to be yelling spec a
lot today
spot spec pistol bullet pistol on air
back hey damn it i mean it is a racket
there's no doubt in my mind that cat can
hear us coming and it's probably scared
out of his mind
get that cat
where's that
so that's that's that's dogs catching
the scent of a mountain lion right there
and that means they found the scent of a
cat and it's time to go
two lions and right as soon as we cross
this hill
i can see the dogs running i can see a
line right out in front
right in the sunshine just smoking
across the desert the one with the color
went this way the dogs and the one
without the color went that way i'm just
hoping we catch one of the two
yeah we'll see
i'll tell you what that's gonna be
interesting down there in that uh open
flat ground that's
i mean i've caught lions before but
never
out and stuff like that
it might get a little rowdy
we got to get down there we're going to
compromise we're good go do your thing
oh it's going to be smooth as silk we
got to protect those dogs we got to get
a dart in that cat
that's when the action and the danger
begins
dogs are off the leash
i'm off the leash my camera drew
i left them in the dust behind
they got all that heavy gear they can't
keep up
one thing is for sure about lion jason
it's never easy
hey
[Music]
so as we come around the corner all i
can see is teeth and claws
dave gets out the perfect shot right
into the front shoulder
we got to go in there start grabbing
dogs before something gets hurt
this is rosie rosie's known to be the
brave one of the bunch
she got her head in the mix literally
and those mountain lions are fully
equipped with a very sharp claws and
when the sharp claw gets you in the
eyebrow that's what happens
a little bit of a spurter there
those wounds are superficial and will
quickly heal fortunately we got in there
and saved the dogs and the cat from
taking it to another level
i'm just trying to get the cat cooled
down grab this dog somebody come here
now lions have a lot of tools and this
one right here they call it the kill
claw
these guys are sharp this one looks like
the end of it might be in rosie's face
over there
last time i saw one of these this close
right there
so the lions north of here they have a
high density prey base they're moving in
100 square mile ranges there's plenty of
food out here in the desert i mean it is
desolate and prey is few and far between
and some lions have to move in ranges up
to a thousand square miles just to find
food so when they come along to a
population of introduced bighorn out
here it's like walking up to a buffet i
mean
they might walk across
miles before seeing one mule deer and
all of a sudden here
is this kind of easy pickings bighorn
and that's when they start hammering
them and bighorn they like rocky point
and they like to be high places and
they're a lot of times easy to see
and mountain lions hunt like people
they're visual
they're really can be really bad on
bighorn sheep especially i think
got some bobbin going on
head up
a little wobbly a little drunk
but the reversal is working now it's
time
to go up there
and catch mom
she's definitely across the valley tim
the dogs are all going that way we're
all going that way then also we get to
beep over here turn the telemetry around
no she's over there dogs all go this way
that sounds
interesting
people are going everywhere we don't
know which way the cat is
that way this way
wow
hot
dry
gnarly
steep
sneaky cat
this is turning out to be
another marathon
way up there dog's finally got this
collared cat she's caught way out on a
pinnacle they got her surrounded not the
most ideal spot for dardiner
you guys
[Music]
ready that's the perfect spot right here
we're going to switch the color out are
you going to well we're going to try and
reinitialize this color first you know
it's all about the color
the whole point of the study is to track
which lions are eating bighorn sheep
let's start getting some fluids in there
tom
the caller tells us when the cats made a
kill and if it's a big horn they're
trying to protect then unfortunately
they'll have to go in and remove that
lion within our project area we probably
have about 500 sheep
and probably about 10 to 15 lions they
kill a
probably a large prey item once per week
on average these lions i think in the
desert though probably a little less
than that so maybe 40 a year
so this cat is probably killed
how many how many animals in its
lifetime 250 maybe
and i mean of that potentially
half of that could be a big horn one
animal this cat
could literally
eat a whole
population a big horn and she looks like
she's uh waking up so we better uh
shimmy down the hill
you know that's uh so unusual to be able
to catch two lions in one day in the
desert like that
so the reversal's kicked in she's
sneaking off going down the hill
today has been a success
two gps callers and two cats now we can
track these predators
i'm going to come back in a few days to
see if either of these cats are hunting
bighorn
but now i've got to return to the
bighorn rescue operation
this time the stakes are way higher
we're moving some rams who are far more
powerful it's going to be a whole
different ball game
so i've got a crazy plan to find out
what i'm up against
wow
when bighorn chief run into each other
it's like a head-on collision of two
cars
and now i'm gonna go out there and try
to capture these guys
there's no way i'm doing this unless i
know exactly what i'm dealing with
you don't mind grabbing that black case
i'll grab my
special device
so this is the zone huh
their headbutts got to be one of the
strongest collisions in nature right
but just how powerful is it i don't
think anyone has ever measured it before
but i've got a plan
there's this ram at the phoenix zoo
named truman and i think he's going to
be the perfect candidate for my
experiment
he really likes to ram this this is his
main area where he gets a lot of his
aggression out i've got this awesome
device here check this out this is
the strike mate what it does is it
measures power like the true power of of
a collision
if he hits it this will be
the only way that anyone has ever read
the ramming power of a bighorn sheep
looking good
so i got the cameras all set up oh great
and there's a couple ways i want to you
know test this out see if it's working i
think i'll start off with a simple punch
all right here we go
5424
not bad
all right
plan b here
i'm going bighorn style i used to play a
little football
you ready
ready all right
down set
wow
anything read
it only says 723
i know
should we stop messing around just
bringing the pro
oh yeah here we go
i like that
are you ready for this man
now you don't want to hit the
yeah now you gotta hit the
the target man
the target
[Applause]
casey's running up and down the fence
line
truman does not like casey being on the
other side of his fence and his mat
and then all of a sudden
yeah
how much was that one
5022. wow oh my gosh he just did the
first hit it's over five thousand okay
it's actually less than what casey did
that's a little embarrassing
hey truman
i'm winning
come on
show us what you got
yeah
good job
5424
dude
i punch harder than you hit with your
horns come on
i know in my heart that he can hit way
more than 5 000.
come on
come on
yeah he dug in deep that time that was
13
900k oh you just killed it shattered the
record that was awesome i mean you can
see because his like feet kicked out he
like just dug in deep look at that's an
awesome number i mean he's gonna be true
off the charts dude
that was a huge hit
we now have a great measurement on the
power of a bighorn rams head and he
wasn't even trying and all of a sudden
he was like bam and that was it that was
just that was beautiful
that that deserves a snack
okay sheep sheep that's 11 o'clock 11
o'clock right there okay yep i got it
so truman's experiment has set me up for
what's coming next i've got to help move
some captive rams into the wild where
they'll help rebuild the bighorn
population this uh
cliff right here man i've got a lot of
turbulence
ready
right
you know the nets on these big rams but
they're still running around jumping
down these cliffs
try to get down there fast
because every
second matters
these captive rams are actually inside
of a giant enclosure but that doesn't
make it any easier
just on this one enclosure
there was 30 mountain lions that were
removed from the ecosystem because they
were trying to take advantage of these
enclosed rams that's a lot of cats
work that off his head i'll get this
other hobble on yeah i got it
hey i need a bag sling bag what where's
my sling bag
we dropped it it's right there in the
bush
therefore we're just color blind all
right right behind us in the bush
you know what they say
if you can't tie knots tie lots of them
okay guys we're ready
all right let's get this guy hooked up
and send him home
that's the ultimate alien abduction
right there that ram is going
for a ride of his life
but next stop after this
out into the wild where he belongs
[Music]
so dave and i
have got a
kill signal from the caller
that we put on that female
quite some time ago
and now we're just gonna sneak in there
and uh
see what they got
maybe a big horn
i'm kind of nervous
i've tracked these cats all over the
darn desert we're soul mates but if
she's killed a horn
then she's done
game over
oh yeah but what i catch on camera is
not what i expect
let's stop talking
i'm thinking it's gonna be right near
the bottom of this slope down here
[Applause]
it's about 300 feet
before the wash down here
so
right there there he is
off the open on the open
wow well
there's one of your desert mountain
vines right there
but really cool to actually get your
eyes on one of these cats
i mean they're super elusive
you know i was really relieved that that
wasn't a bighorn sheep
because now
the cat gets to live
just kind of feeling her teeth there
feels like a younger deer
i mean there's so much of this mule deer
doe here it's a perfect opportunity
for me to set up my remote cameras oh
yeah come back mr kitty
[Music]
is it the cat
no
it's a coyote
not just one coyote
but two
and they drag this sucker off down the
hill and chow down
man
it's tough it's tough out here in the
desert
and this poor cat
walking across the desert
finds some easy little herd of four mule
deer takes one out
tucks it up underneath the tree
comes back
it's already been taken away by a pack
of coyotes
these desert cats definitely have it
tough out here
but i have to admit i'm more worried
about the bighorn sheep than i am about
the mountain lions
there's just not enough lamb surviving
to keep the herd numbers up
the use we released well one of them has
given birth
the question is
where's the lamb
sounds pretty loud sounds really loud
yeah
so she's right up on this this hill
right up on this slope
we've got to get a color on the lamb
today if we want to monitor its survival
and newborn lambs are easy pickings for
mountain lions
weather's blowing in it's getting dark
we don't catch this lamb tonight it's
not gonna get a collar so
hopefully rebecca and i can find it here
if i find it first you owe me a beer
okay i've got some at the house
well i'll tell you what
looking for these lambs it's definitely
like looking for a needle in the
haystack
except for
when you uh
oh look at this right here
got it
bingo
i have my official lamb gloves on if i
can do anything
okay
i mean when it comes to
wild babies it doesn't get any cuter
than this
these are the little guys that
we're trying to protect
here in new mexico
all of this management of the predators
really boils down to these little guys i
mean
the more
cute little guys like this that can
survive the better he's peeing on you
well babies a baby's a baby and every
once in a while you haven't lived until
you've been beat up by a baby
i'm going to attempt to get a weight on
him so if you could try
he doesn't weigh as much as he did about
a minute ago i know it
[Music]
you